oh yeah
[Music]
Morgana explorers has searched for
centuries the Golden City it's a
technological marvel technically became
if anyone found out what we truly are
what we possess
it could destroy the white man it is my
duty to protect it
my son it is your time vomiting oh cool
cool cool
the king of Wakanda is here
how much more uniting cotton you are war
stood smoke over it is lighter
[Music]
completely it absorbs energy for
redistribution
black pant I waited my entire life for
this
the world's gonna start over I'm gonna
be on top what do you want I want the
tomorrow
the revolution will not be televised
[Music]
hey everybody's surprised new Black
Panther trailer showing off all the new
technology including some more details
about what the new black panther suit
does so let's break it down and if
you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything
there'll be a new ticket giveaway at the
end of the video too but starting with
the most important stuff first let's
talk about the suit Sheree says that it
also absorbs and helps redirect energy
redistribution is the word that she uses
now there been a couple different
versions of the costume in the comics
the ones that form around him the way
that Iron Man's costumes form around him
he used to have the briefcase suit
during Iron Man 2 that still required a
bunch of technology that he had to step
into the infinity war Iron Man suit
looks a little more modular like the
extremis armor something that just forms
out of very small pieces of technology
so you can literally walk around with
jewelry like a necklace that you see
here so you get to see a little bit of
that in action during all these big city
chase scenes that look like they're
happening around the casino scene where
they wind up capturing ulysses klaw so
the way they cut the trailer isn't
linear like you're getting scenes from
the middle of the movie before you get
scenes from the beginning of the movie
in the end of the movie you get a better
look at black panther versus kill monger
and his golden Jaguar costume this scene
here where golden Jaguar looks like he's
getting ready to kill Sheree and black
panther tackles him into that big chasm
that seems like it's coming from all
these scenes where they're fighting in
the vibranium mines you actually get a
much better picture of that too you see
this giant mound with the train going
around it so it helps provide you with
some visual imagery of what the great
mound looks like that's what they refer
to it as but it's really just this giant
alien meteorite that crashed to earth
just happened to crash in their
territory around all the tribes which is
how Wakanda became the Wakanda of today
you get a more complete look at some of
these ships it seems like they've just
finished a lot of the CG so they can
actually show it to you now
usually they try to hide stuff like that
really early on when they're still
working on post-production but the
movies almost done is coming out in
February you get a little more of the
story of kill monger trying to take the
throne of Wakanda so that he can conquer
the entire earth we're starting again
I'm gonna be on top like they help all
this advanced technology they're the
most advanced nation on the
and why wouldn't they rule the earth the
whole idea is that there are multiple
tribes within Wakanda
not everybody agrees what their course
of action should be what their lifestyle
should be like so you have a lot of
traditionalists you have a lot of
militaristic people then you have black
panther who has to find a way to keep
everything from exploding because as
they say it's your time now he hasn't
taken the throne yet so Marvel Simba has
to become The Lion King or the Panther
King however you want to talk about it
there's still all kinds of speculation
about the soul gem I know everybody's
wondering about the Dajjal eeeh maybe
this might be it maybe it's inside the
great mountain maybe that has something
to do with vibranium special properties
in the MCU there's still a number of
ways they could explain it within the
context of the Black Panther mythos but
I would be very surprised if they gave
that away in the trailers Kevin Feige
has explained a little bit about the
role of vibranium and Black Panthers
powers in the Cinematic Universe because
they always change a few things from the
comics they simplify a little bit the
reason the heart-shaped herb gives him
his powers has strength his enhanced
abilities in the movie universe is
because it grows in vibranium tainted
soil and has done so for hundreds and
hundreds of years so you have people
eating of that that's what gives them
their abilities but it does remain to be
seen if the source of all this flows
back to an infinity gem because it does
feel like a very cosmic thing and we
know that the meteorite is alien it came
from outer space somewhere but they're
leaving that for the movies to explain
so just don't pin all your hopes on a
soul gem on Black Panther but it is the
leading candidate now that we have one
more movie before infinity war if they
didn't just save it for the actual
infinity war movie but I've already done
a couple videos on Thanos and the
infinity gems that we see him wielding
during the infinity war trailer it's
always possible that that's deceptive
too like he could actually have more
gems than we see and they just remove
them with CG or they didn't add them
just to mislead people so it didn't give
away too much of the plot they did a
really good job of that with the Thor
Ragnarok trailers so as to not give away
the big twist at the end of the movie
but just because this trailer focuses so
much more on the designs of Wakanda the
technology let me know what is your
favorite part of this like what about
the vibranium car that it looks like
Sheree is driving she's affected
their version of Tony Stark just much
much younger and I don't know if they
share any scenes during infinity war but
I just can't wait to see them compare
gadgets we can assume that Black
Panthers gonna meet up with Iron Man at
some point and they'll compare
technology like hey that's some pretty
cool tech you got there on that suit
where he tries to pick his brain about
and get some secrets but we don't know
how sure he is going to be used in the
movie yet other than giving Captain
America some Panther gauntlets and some
extra technology before this huge fight
but what's gonna happen next is is I'll
be posting my non-spoilery Star Wars the
last Jedi review I had a chance to see
the movie and the embargo is going to be
up tomorrow so look out for that I was
planning on doing a spider-man venom
video soon too before this drop so we'll
try to get that out as soon as possible
too but just leave all your bonus video
requests in the comments below there's a
new round of that imax ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a Marvel related
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from that Jessica Jones video
that I did Jack Lichtenstein
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for brand new Star Wars the last Jedi
and you can click here to rewatch the
infinity war trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight